voilà monsieur bonsoir dans deux minutes
jacques chirac devrait intervenir en
direct de l'elysée le président devrait
annoncer l'arrêt définitif des essais
nucléaires français
un souterrain dans le pacifique sud nous
reviendrons bien sûr sur les
conséquences militaires diplomatiques et
politiques de cette décision l'autre
grand titre de ce journal de 20h
concernera bien évidemment les
inondations désastreuses qui touche
depuis la nuit dernière le département
de l'hérault et notamment la région de
puisserguier où il est tombé hier
dimanche en quelques heures entre 150 et
200 litres d'eau au m² innovations qui
ont fait au moins quatre victimes et des
dégâts matériels considérables le
premier ministre alain juppé s'est rendu
sur place est très libre et il a annoncé
une aide d'urgence
nous retrouverons en direct hacker
leenhardt ses invités et l'ensemble de
nos envoyés spéciaux
au sommaire de ce journal également la
libération des 17 otages français
retenus au yémen les remous autour de la
décision d'imposer un plafond de
ressources au versement de l'allocation
pour jeunes enfants et la forte odeur de
cocaïne qui flotte sur certains cours de
tennis dans quelques instants nous
allons rejoindre le palais de l'elysée
d'où le président de la république
jacques chirac va s'adresser en direct
aux français arlette chabot on prévoit
l'annnonce de l'arrêt définitif des
essais nucléaires français
oui alors nous verrons effectivement ce
que dit président de la république il
faut simplement rappeler si vous voulez
que le chef de l'état avait annoncé
cette décision le 13 juin dernier que le
premier de tir d'essai dans le pacifier
qu'avait eu lieu au début du mois de
septembre et que le dernier le 6e peut
être le dernier de ses deux présidents
annoncent la fin de ces essais le
dernier tir a eu lieu dans la nuit de
samedi à dimanche
le président avait dit 8 au maximum si
effectivement les résultats de cette
dernière expérimentation sont
satisfaisants et bien et on pourrait
s'arrêter là et mettre un terme donc
définitivement aux essais nucléaires
français
je rappelle qu'il y avait deux objectifs
c'était de tester la nouvelle arme
nucléaire qui équipera les sous marins
français
et puis la simulation des armes
nucléaires voilà réponse dans trois
secondes nous allons retrouver l'elysée
mes chers compatriotes je vous annonce
ce soir la veille définitif des essais
nucléaires français
grâce à l'ultime série qui vient d'être
effectué la france disposera durablement
d'une défense fiable et moderne la
sécurité de notre pays celle de nos
enfants est assuré
où je sais que la décision que j'ai
prise en juin dernier a pu provoquer en
france et ailleurs
inquiétude et émotion si ma résolution
n'en a pas été affectée
je n'ai pas été insensible à ces
mouvements d'opinion il témoigne de
l'attachement croissant des habitants de
la terre à la sécurité collective et à
la sauvegarde de l'environnement
ces populations sont aussi les miennes
je sais que le nucléaire peut faire peur
mais dans un monde toujours dangereux
qu'il s'agit pour nous d'une arme de
dissuasion
c'est à dire d'une arme au service de la
paix aujourd'hui j'ai le sentiment
d'avoir accompli l'un des premiers
devoirs de ma charge
en donnant à la france pour les
décennies qui viennent les moyens de son
indépendance et de sa sécurité
un nouveau chapitre s'ouvre la france
comme elle s'y est engagée va jouer un
rôle actif et déterminé pour le
désarmement dans le monde
et aussi pour une meilleure défense
européenne je prendrai les initiatives
en ce sens en cours des prochaines
semaines
comme chacun de vous chers compatriotes
je veux la paix une paix solide une paix
durable
nous le savons tous la paix comme la
liberté se construit chaque jour
c'est le sens de la décision que j'ai
prise il se sera l'exigence de mon
action pour demain voilà une allocution
très courte 2 minutes 30 et très
rapidement arlette un premier
commentaire à chaud
oui bien en annonçant la reprise des
essais nucléaires en conscience suivant
l'avis des experts et pour assurer la
fiabilité et la sûreté de la force
nucléaire française le président de la
république avait au fond prix du riz
celui de provoquer une réaction
internationale forte notamment des pays
du pacifique mais aussi de certains nous
partenaires européens et second risque
et bien suscité un scepticisme chez les
français qui n'attendaient pas ses
décisions parmi les premières du nouveau
septennat des français également troublé
par des condamnations internationales
alors si remous sans doute conduit on
l'a dit le président a accéléré
l'expérimentation
elle se termine ce soir on avait dit au
plus tard fin mai et à réduire aussi le
nombre de tirs
alors aujourd'hui la crédibilité de la
force nucléaire est affirmée l'opinion
internationale certainement apaiser par
les engagements répétés ce soir jacques
chirac peut reprendre l'initiative
au plan international sur le désarmement
la france devrait annoncer très vite
qu'elle signera le traité d'interdiction
des essais dans le pacifique sud et plus
largement le président français pèsera
de tout son poids en faveur de la
signature du prochain traité interdisant
définitivement tous les essais
nucléaires
jacques chirac peut aussi plus
facilement mettre en chantier la grande
réflexion sur la défense de la france
des composantes de la force de
dissuasion jusqu'à la réforme du service
national une loi de programmation
militaire devrait être votée avant l'été
voilà au delà des péripéties de six
derniers mois et bien le chef de l'état
souhaite sans doute que l'on retienne
une leçon la politique de défense de la
faune
se décide à paris et elle est bien fixée
partiel de l'état merci nous reviendrons
bien sûr tout à l'heure sur cette
information d'arrêt des essais
nucléaires français dans le pacifique et
sur ses conséquences aussi bien
militaires diplomatiques que politique
auparavant nous allons bien évidemment
consacré une large place de ce journal
aux inondations qui ont touché le
département de l'hérault où le plan
orsec a été déclenché cette nuit à la
suite de fortes pluies qui ont notamment
affecté la région de puisserguier
inondations qui ont fait au moins quatre
victimes le premier ministre alain juppé
s'est rendu sur place cet après midi
reportage de nos envoyés spéciaux
christophe la rocca holy dis qu'on vous
allez voir notre caméra également a pris
l'eau il pleut toujours sur puisserguier
mécaniquement les habitants déblayent
maisons et commerces
mais personne n'ose vraiment se plaindre
des dégâts matériels
qu'est ce qui nous est arrivé on va
savoir
j'ai vu les voitures partir j'ai vu des
monsieurs partie des enfants partir vous
s'est passé c'est aussi car c'est
vraiment une scène d'apocalypse qui
s'est jouée ici les voitures renversées
atteste de la force du courant qui a
balayé les rues ici il y avait une fête
foraine quand l'orage a éclaté
un orage d'une violence exceptionnelle
la terre déjà gorgés d'eau n'a
absorbé en dix minutes l'eau est montée
jusqu'à 1 m 60 dans les rues samedi à
miami dégustation la première fois porté
par loi déjà mais c'est pas grave je ne
peux pas vous dire de tommy haas est
inouïe j'ai jamais vu ça je vous assure
quand vous voyez passer des gens sur des
toits de voitures qui hurlent et il n'y
a rien à faire ça un courant
c'est pas dans ça moi je la porte qui a
failli céder j'avais mon fils en mangent
les vite monté et plus rien à faire dans
cette nuit d'horreur trois personnes ont
perdu la vie à puisserguier une femme de
61 ans et deux enfants âgés de 9 et 7
ans à malaga ce un village voisin un
homme d'une soixantaine d'années a
également péri emportées par les eaux
mais le bilan aurait pu être bien pire
encore voici l'école de puisserguier
le niveau d'eau est encore inscrit sur
les murs cet après midi alain juppé a
visité le village
il s'est rendu compte par lui-même avant
d'accorder une aide exceptionnelle à
puisserguier une aide d'urgence vont
être débloqués
dès demain par le ministre de
l'intérieur pour faire face aux
situations les plus difficiles
par ailleurs j'ai demandé au préfet
d'accélérer la procédure de déclaration
de catastrophe naturelle de façon que
l'indemnisation complémentaire aux
assurances puissent être mises en place
au plus vite possible à puisserguier il
faudra certainement des mois pour
réparer les dégâts
mais jamais on ne pourra oublier ici ce
qui s'est passé hier on l'a vue
manifestement tout le monde a été
surpris par la très brusque montée des
eaux à commencer par les responsables de
la sécurité civile et les pompiers
locaux qui ont fait face vaille que
vaille à cette situation dramatique
reportage à cardoze raymond sa place ici
les différentes équipes de secours n'ont
toujours pas évacué les meubles et
différents dégâts matériels
vingt-quatre heures après 24 heures
après que l'orage est complètement
dévastée cet appartement
voyez le lot commun est l'atout tout
changer de place c'est arrivé en même
temps ça a été très vite monsieur nous
sommes rentrés moi et mon mari on a
commencé à sortir méchamment maritale
apporte moi je suis allé à la cuisine
les deux portes aux m'éclater et l'ol et
elle est arrivée comme une bombe
toute la journée le village a vécu au
rythme des secours ceux des pompiers des
gendarmes ou des militaires mais ici
personne n'arrive à comprendre pourquoi
ces inondations ont fait tant de dégâts
pourquoi celle qu'a pu connaître puis
séguier il ya trois ans était bien moins
importante
au niveau l'opération peut-être restés
clos jungle c'est sérieux que quand
l'ombre mais abordait pourtant m les
voitures ont en effet été balayé par le
courant en moins d'un quart d'heure
un quart d'heure avant qu'elles ne
viennent s'encastrer les unes contre les
autres
à la sortie du village si l'arrivée de
cette importance il n'y a pas et ça ne
peut pas être rationné
même avec toutes les précautions
possibles et imaginables même avec tous
les sous courts possibles et imaginables
il était impossible de prévoir les
conséquences d'une vague de simple
fatalité ou catastrophes dont on aurait
dû prévenir certains risques c'est sans
doute une question que l'on se pose
chaque année et chaque année il est
toujours aussi difficile de trouver une
réponse
ce village est bien évidemment en état
de choc que je vous propose de retrouver
tout de suite en direct de puisserguier
notre envoyé spécial est un énarque avec
ses invités
oui bonsoir bruno effectivement
puisserguier reste ce soir en état de
choc pour vous donner une idée de
l'orage qu'il y avait hier pendant deux
heures il est tombé à peu près autant
d'eau qu'ils tombent en général en trois
mois d'hiver et vous voyez j'imagine sur
ces images que la pluie continue à
tomber depuis le début de l'après midi
il n'a cessé de pleuvoir pour vous
donner aussi une idée de la force du
torrent qui a traversé le village hier
je propose de regarder juste à côté de
moi il y a une dizaine de camions
citernes qui était garée dans un parking
et bien sous l'effet du torrent ces
camions ont reculé d'une dizaine de
mètres
ils ont fait céder un mur qui séparait
le parking d'une habitation résidentiel
et l'un de ses camions s'est immobilisée
vous le voyez juste au dessus de la
piscine de la personne qui habite qui
habitent ici à puisserguier alors j'ai à
mes côtés madame le maire merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous je sais que vous n'avez
pas dormi depuis plus de plus de 24
heures je voulais savoir comment dans
quel état sont ce soir les 2500
habitants est ce qu'ils sont d'une
certaine manière résigné résigné non non
on peut pas être résigné devant des
catastrophes importantes
peut-être pas résigné mais ils sont
solidaires solidaire et actif et toute
la population je tiens d'abord à
remercier tous les administrés le
personnel communal les pompiers tous mes
collègues tous les élus du gouvernement
lui-même le maire régine hua travailler
seulement de continuer à travailler
toute la nuit et tout donner alors à vos
côtés le colonel de casseurs qui dirige
les pompiers de l'hérault merci beaucoup
mais on connaît le d'être avec nous
quelques quel est le bilan que l'on peut
dresser en termes de vies humaines
d'abord il y a quatre personnes qui sont
mortes
est ce qui vient encore des disparus ce
soir tout à fait alors nous déplorons
quatre victimes dans le département
malheureusement ici 3,3 victime et une
autre victime au nord de au nord de
béziers à côté d'une commune de magalas
en ce qui concerne le disparu nous avons
été très inquiet hier soir bien entendu
puisque des informations très alarmante
nouveau-né dans salle opérationnelle
tendant à dire que des personnes étaient
disparues ce matin
nous avons fait tous les recherches est
en fait nous avons trouvé ici ici ici un
soulagement mais par contre dans une
autre commune
quelqu'un qui était recherché
effectivement et qu'on a trouvés et on
le disait dans l'un des reportages mon
colonel c'est un hasard certes mais il y
avait hier soir le loto des pompiers ici
à puisserguier de très nombreux pompiers
étaient présents à ce loto et ils ont
spontanément comme ça sauver des vies
humaines
tout à fait oui si on peut déplorer ici
malheureusement je crois que c'est une
émotion très grande ici 3-3 décédé je
crois que il faut dire aussi que les
pompiers qui est qui ont sauvé aussi des
vies humaines en prenant des risques
énormes pour leur vie pour sauver donc
sauver ou périr on on a su ici ce que ça
voulait dire on un dernier mot mon
colonel on l'a dit ils continuent à
pleuvoir cette nuit est ce que vous êtes
inquiet pour la région depuis servi ou
peut-être plus en aval du côté de la mer
du côté de valras et bien les puits que
nous avons actuellement donc sont pas de
nature à nous inquiéter
le problème c'est que les terrains
n'absorbe plus est cette eau va se
retrouver dans l'orb et peut-être faire
remonter un peu l'ordre mais ça nous
inquiète pas outre mesure
voilà bruno je vous le disais 500
pompiers restent mobilisés toute la nuit
et et le personnel de la mairie les
habitants puisserguier continuerons à
travailler toute la nuit pour tenter de
sauver ce qui peut encore l'être
merci pour que ces témoignages les
intempéries ont entraîné l'interruption
une bonne partie de cette journée de la
circulation ferroviaire entre narbonne
et béziers
ce matin lors d'une conférence de presse
le préfet du département a indiqué que
plus de cent mille personnes sont
menacées par la montée des eaux dans la
région d'agadez de sérignan l'orb a
débordé former un immense marécage
reportage de nos envoyés spéciaux
patrice volé puis jean-françois
giorgetti
toujours la pluie ce soir autour de
béziers et pour aller au village par ici
pas la peine d'insister la plupart des
routes d'accès à sérignan sont coupés
alors par là peut-être mais pose espoirs
de l'eau toujours de l'eau
jusqu à un bon mètre par endroits le
vieux village et isolé pour la deuxième
fois en deux mois
vous avez été prévenus ah oui on a
témoigné c'était la catastrophe
le monde a été surpris laissé la sienne
ne marchait pas
bon voilà hier ils ont fait ce qu'il
fallait tout le moins d'être convertis
c'est l'américaine qu à une vitesse pour
être avalisé les autres un des hommes à
rome pour ça le dr il ya 2 3 2 3 points
de la rivière mais chaque fois qu'il ya
une inondation après on ne peut qu
aurait alors la solidarité s'organise
vaille que vaille
ces jeunes recherchent leur grand-père
pas de nouvelles depuis ce matin doit
être m dos à m trenitalia une demi-heure
de béziers à la mer un vaste plan d'eau
des centaines de maisons encerclé ou
inondés à sérignan comme à valras dans
ce hameau ce matin deux personnes âgées
ont été évacués il fallait partir après
une nuit d'inquiétude mais selon les
pompiers
le plus dur est passé
il n'y aura pas de montée des eaux dans
la nuit donc la situation est
relativement sereine
maintenant il y aura énormément de
travail par la suite de pompage de
nettoyage d'assèchement de bilan tous
maintenant attendre la décrue à sérignan
pas une goutte d'eau n'était tombé
d'octobre à décembre dernier ici la
nature a perdu le sens de la mesure
on l'a dit fort heureusement météo
france prévoit pour demain une
atténuation des pluies sur cette région
la station météo du mont aigoual dans
les cévennes a enregistré un record
historique du peu visitée pour un mois
de janvier depuis un siècle
1040 de litres d'eau tombés par mètre
carré depuis le 1er janvier soit la
moitié de la moyenne annuelle
en fait ces inondations dévastatrices
ont pour origine une convergence de
facteurs d'explication à nos consignes
et nîmes le 3 octobre 1988 des trombes
d'eau dévale les rues de la ville et
transforment en autant de pièges les
parkings les voitures et les ruelles
la crue fait 10 morts vaison la romaine
nouvelle sort violemment de son lit la
rivière emporte sur son passage des
habitations construites en zone
inondable et eu 37 personnes c'était le
22 septembre 1992 de crue exceptionnelle
de référence en matière de catastrophes
auxquelles on peut comparer la dernière
inondation de l'hérault animant 88 il
était tombé 420 mm d'eau en moins de 6
heures à vélo en 92 300 mm et hier dans
l'hérault entre 150 et 200 mm mais cette
fois dans la région de puisserguier les
pluies diluviennes sont tombées sur un
sol déjà saturé d'eau
il y a huit ans anime la crue s'étaient
ajoutés à seulement 39 millimètres d'eau
tombés le mois précédent alors que dans
l'hérault
elle s'est ajoutée à une pluviométrie
record au mois de janvier
pourquoi les orages du sud sont ils
toujours si violent parce que la côte
méditerranéenne est bordée de relief sur
lesquels buttent l'humidité marine elle
s'y accumulent et se décharge
brutalement et le relief encore lui
canalise l'inondation en torrent d'une
violence parfois inouïe ailleurs en
france dans les zones de plaine
on peut plus facilement dompter les
rivières mais dans le sud est
ces aménagements ne sont guère
souhaitable sur ce type ce type
d'événement sur tes petits bassins
versants en fait on peut pas grand chose
sinon il faudrait couvrir tous les
petits bassins versants de petite
retenue
ça coûterait horriblement cher il faudra
faire partout et on transmet on dénature
totalement le paysage français canaliser
les cours d'eau c'est aussi parfois
provoqué des crues encore plus violente
en aval il reste deux manières d'agir
empêcher la construction de nouvelles
habitations en zone inondable et rester
très vigilant sur les alertes météo
lorsque les vieux village eux-mêmes se
trouve en zone dangereuse
c'était le cas à puisserguier la
situation est revenue quasiment normale
en fin d'après midi en corse du sud ou
dans la soirée d'hier de fortes pluies
avait fait sortir plusieurs rivières de
leur lit sur le littoral sud-est des
pontes était submergé plusieurs autres
coupes et des bungalows de vacances
emporté huit personnes ont dû être
évacuées par hélicoptère il n'y a pas eu
de blessé mais les dégâts vous l'avez vu
les dégâts matériels sont prêts très
important le 22 septembre 92 la rivière
ouvèze se transformer en torrent de boue
emportant tout sur son passage
avec 37 morts la cité de vaison la
romaine dans le vaucluse payé un très
lourd tribut
un peu plus de trois ans après les
autorités ont elles tiré toutes les
conséquences de ce drame
reportage du d'idiot thierry monnier le
22 septembre 1992 l'ouvèze autrefois si
paisible des bordels au binôme sera
lourd 43 morts et quelque 500
des gars il faut panser les plaies
surtout éviter que cela ne se reproduise
c'est pourquoi d'importants travaux ont
été effectués on a nettoyé le lead
nouvelle et ses berges ont été surélevés
et renforcé il ya eu certaines endroits
qui ont été élargies d'autres qui ont
été confortés avait les construction de
digues des reconstruction de digues
et puis il nous reste à terminer
l'aménagement de la rivière en aval de
la ville sûre pour des travaux qui nous
reste à faire encore d'ici la fin
d'année
mais on a pu aussi d'autres mesures plus
radicales ici il y avait un lotissement
et un centre commercial trop exposé il
n'existe plus il y en a de même pour
l'ancienne école qui autrefois se
dressaient sur cette place le camping a
également été déplacés sur les hauteurs
autant de mesures qui rassure c'est vrai
que l'ouvèze est beaucoup plus canalisé
aujourd'hui il est vrai que j'ai eu des
gens qui sont partis d'eux des abords de
la rivière où ça nous pose aucun
problème
déplacer les populations à risque
restent la seule véritable parade
vouloir donner ce ticket une crue
semblable à celle de septembre 92 serait
illusoire ou s'est rasé vezeau mousseux
des murs de quelques mètres qui par
rapport aux sites sont guère possible
pour pas dire impossible
ou bien prévoir des ouvrages à un
souterraines pour évacuer l'eau je ne
sais pas mais ça représente des
milliards de froid pour l'avoir vécu on
c'est ici qu'on ne peut pas canaliser
une nature capricieuse c'est parfois ce
soir saison la romaine solidaire a le
regard tourné vers le département de
l'hérault
au yémen les 17 touristes français
libérés sont arrivés dans la capitale
sanaa en milieu de journée ils ont
confirmé avoir été bien traités par
leurs ravisseurs
ces dix sept otages dont 13 femmes vont
prendre l'avion séduit pour paris les
autorités yéménites affirment d'autre
part que cette libération a été obtenue
sans aucune contrepartie thierry
thuillier
ils se portent bien sourit devant la
caméra se sont pourtant d'anciens otages
les 17 touristes français kidnappé il ya
cinq jours viennent d'être libérés
et il s'apprête à prendre la route de
sanaa la capitale yéménite
escorté par l'armée régulière est
accompagné par l'ambassadeur de france
un convoi qui arrive en milieu de
journée au premier poste de contrôle de
sanaa très bien très bien très bien
couvert très bien où il a été libéré ce
matin à 6 heures et on a été vraiment
bien reçus pour lire par les ravisseurs
des cadeaux en puissance au moment du
départ et même les femmes sont serrées
entre elles et tout et puis avant sa
passe est extraordinaire à sanaa ils se
rendent immédiatement à l'ambassade de
france
l'ambassadeur a été constamment présent
mais il a laissé les autorités yéménites
mener les discussions après l'ambassade
direction l'hôtel et quelques heures de
repos odile et marie madeleine ne sort
pourtant pas très marquée par leur
mésaventure en tout cas jamais
explique-t-elle elles n'ont eu peur
vous pouvez aller et venir dans la
maison des montés sur la terrasse et on
nous a amené le matin l'après-midi vit
avec sa compagne et bien sûr par des
bédouins
on a eu une impression favorable
j'en veux soir les dix sept ex otages
sont invités à l'ambassade de france
avant de rouler ensemble dernière fois
dans un restaurant de sanaa les
autorités yéménites affirment ce soir
que la libération des touristes français
s'est fait sans contrepartie
cette nouvelle prise d'otage est en tout
cas terminé comme toutes les précédentes
au yémen le plus pacifiquement possible
quant aux dix-sept ressortissants
français ils regagneront la france par
un vol régulier cette nuit à paris la
délinquance a baissé de plus de 6 % 95
par rapport à 94 les crimes et délits
passant sous la barre du chiffre de
référence des trois cent mille selon le
préfet de police philippe massoni cette
baisse a été acquise avant la mise en
oeuvre du plan antiterroriste vigipirate
mais elle a été bien évidemment
renforcée grâce à la multiplication des
patrouilles de police le même jour le
ministère de l'intérieur a présenté un
rapport baptisé hlm et sécurité un bilan
qui dresse un constat sévère de la
situation dans un certain nombre de
cités où se multiplient ce que les
spécialistes appellent les actes
d'incivilité toutes ces petites choses
qui empoisonnent littéralement la vie
quotidienne exemple avec ce reportage de
maryse burgot et philippe deslandes qui
ont suivi une postière affecté dans un
quartier sensible de gennevilliers près
de paris
tous les matins depuis trois ans les
mêmes gestes
le tri du courrier puis le départ vers
le quartier du luth à gennevilliers
l'une des cités les plus sensibles de la
banlieue parisienne sur les pourtours
une tournée vélo conte pour les voitures
j'ai pris la 3 ans qu'elle a quitté sa
campagne normande contre les hlm du
lutte pour monter en grade à la poste il
faut souvent passer par la banlieue
parisienne
mais dès son arrivée ici nicole lecomte
a très mal vécu sa nouvelle affectation
pour toujours rassurée parce que s'y
passe
adam arrêter quelqu'un je n'y fit pour
le coup j mais je m'y attendais pas j'ai
eu peur d'un seul coup ça m'a fait peur
peur sentiment d'insécurité qu'ils
soient policiers convient de facteurs
les agents publics sont de plus en plus
réticents à accepter des postes en
quartiers difficiles
bikindi ce type d'incivilités répéter
ces petits actes de délinquance comme
les injures qui rendent la vie
quotidienne impossible j'étais en train
de prendre mon vélo je vais même pas vu
les personnes passaient en voiture j'ai
rien il n'a crié dans la boîte 6 euros
la fac qui est sabordé [ __ ] voilà
qu'est ce que vous avez pensé à ce
moment là
j'ai pensé bon que j'avais rien à dire
puisque je n'y vois là un acte qui sera
désormais passible de 50 mille francs
d'amendé d'un an de prison
mais beaucoup d'autres incivilités ne
font toujours pas l'objet d'une
qualification pénale ce qui participe au
sentiment d'insécurité
donc les gens se trouvent face à une
multiplication de petits incidents qui
les rendent pour certains jeux les sites
à moitié fous et ils se disent je suis
bloqué je suis un peu comme un rat dans
un trou je peux plus sortir de chez moi
sans avoir à faire face tout devient
compliqué et je sens qu à la fois mon
bailleur hlm est aussi mon maire n'ont
pas plus d'éléments de réponse que moi
nicole lecomte n'a jamais louer
d'appartements à gennevilliers depuis
trois ans elle vit tout foyer de la
poste en attendant avec impatience sa
mutation chez elle en normandie
les enseignants d'un lycée de colombes
dans les hauts-de-seine ont décidé la
suspension des cours après l'agression
du principal de ce lycée par jeunes
extérieurs à cet établissement
d'autre part les enseignants du collège
louise-michel de saint-etienne du
rouvray en seine maritime ont décidé de
ne pas reprendre les cours comme prévu
ce matin et ce jusqu'à jeudi afin de
protester je cite contre le climat de
violence généralisée et l'insécurité
croissante
chantal kimmerlin et daniel levy ont
rencontré certains de ces jeunes à
l'origine des troubles de la semaine
dernière hpd la grille c'est par ce soir
encore les profs des élèves les plus
dures du collège
malgré quelques tentatives amical n'est
isolé
on n'a pas su se parler avant le
dialogue avec nous ils ont une mauvaise
image de nous et je crois que vous
prenez des délinquances
ils disent qu'ils nous menacent ils vont
le tuer c'est pour ça qu'ils peuvent pas
dire non ils ont peur de dialoguer avec
nous pourtant ce matin ils avaient été
conviés avec leurs parents à venir
parler des problèmes nés ils ne sont pas
venus
sans eux les enseignants et quelques
parents ont commencé à dire tout haut ce
qu'ils subissent ici depuis des mois et
des familles ont en fait il n'ya pas il
ya des enjeux et les bousculades
il ya beaucoup d'agressions verbales
l'épave innovation physique place on va
voir il ya des balles les voitures qui
sont abîmés enfin un ensemble de faits
qu'il faut que l'on vit effectivement
d'emploi de violence des faits
inacceptables pour l'épreuve des
comportements justifié pour certains
élèves ignorent et ignoble et essaie de
tisser des données des bonnes réponses
même s'ils sont français et gna ils
disent ouais tu fout le bordel là j'ai
une professeure de français là à nous la
respectons pas les élèves a les traits
de l'autre fois quand elle énervée à
traiter les élèves de légumes de cons
tout ça à ses nerfs foyen puis les
professeurs aujourd'hui et que nous on
les respecte
c'est avec au fait des efforts par
exemple le matin contre les serbian
ouvrir la porte et on dirait qu'ils sont
fatigués zone au maroc comme ça vous
dirait qu'ils ont pas envie de me voir
le rectorat nom sera certainement des
moyens supplémentaires pour mieux
fonctionner mais il n'est pas dit que
ses moyens financiers arrange les
relations entre les adultes et certains
élèves la violence toujours et la
télévision couple pervers sujet d'un
colloque extrêmement sérieux aujourd'hui
au sénat parmi les intervenants le
président de france télévisions jean
pierre elkabbach qui a appelé la
profession à s'imposer des règles et à
réfléchir aux moyens de canaliser la
violence sur le petit écran tout en
rejetant l'idée de censure y est d'ordre
moral
même préoccupation aux etats-unis où le
président un briefing tonnes dans son
discours sur l'état de l'union a insisté
pour que la victime soit intégrée à la
future loi sur les télécoms
cette puce anti-violence installés dans
les téléviseurs
devrait permettre aux parents de
programmer le zapping automatique des
programmes jugés trop violents
comme promis retour à la non se fait à
20 heures précises par le président de
la république jacques chirac que l'arrêt
définitif des essais nucléaires français
dans le pacifique sud après une toute
dernière rafale de sites est au lieu des
8 prévus initialement
apparemment les scientifiques ont pu
faire les estimations qui était
nécessaire au mieux le bonheur une
énergie 8 fois supérieure à celle
d'hiroshima
c'était il ya 48 heures afin de gâteaux
faits à l'image de cette 6ème explosions
en tout trois tirs les plus puissants de
cette campagne entre 60 et 120 kilos
tonnes ont permis d'atteindre un
objectif essentiel officiellement il
s'agit de garantir la sûreté et la
fiabilité des armes nucléaires de la
france c'est à dire de valider le bon
fonctionnement de la tête nucléaire
tn 75 celle qui équipera les missiles
embarqués dans les sous marins lanceurs
d'engins nouvelle génération du type
triomphant ces derniers tirs ont été
l'occasion d'effectuer un test de
développement final notamment sur des
modifications de la charge de larmes en
utilisant davantage de plutonium
techniquement l'armée prête à jouer son
rôle dans la dissuasion
les trois autres tirs de cette campagne
commencée le 5 septembre dernier on
dégageait beaucoup moins d'énergie
il s'agissait de recueillir le maximum
de données pour accélérer la mise au
point de la simulation pour l'instant
les expérimentations laboratoire nos
mises en évidence que quelques éléments
partiels de l' explosion thermonucléaire
les trois essais ont permis d'en savoir
plus notamment sur la lunette qui donne
alarme toute sa puissance
le temps presse pour reconstituer toutes
les pièces du puzzle
la simulation doit prendre le relais
avant 2015 avant que les armes actuelles
ne soient périmés en principe
précisément devrait être signé avant la
fin de cette année 96 un traité
interdisant tout essai nucléaire quel
qu'il soit les pays les plus avancés
techniquement travailleront désormais
sur les simulations nucléaire une
technique particulièrement sophistiqué
et d'un coût financier qui risque d'être
exorbitants explications françois corner
dans les entrailles des sous marins
nucléaires lanceurs d'engins au fond des
silos à terre sur la rampe de lancement
ou sur le ventre des bombardiers
stratégiques 650 mille fois l'énergie de
la bombe d'hiroshima sur la planète
c'est la puissance estimée des arsenaux
des états membres du club nucléaire les
etats-unis la russie le royaume uni la
chine et la france
auxquels il faut rajouter les pays dits
du seuil ukraine kazakhstan biélorussie
israël afrique du sud et inde
à genève les négociations se poursuivent
sur le traité international visant à
l'interdiction des essais nucléaires
dans le monde qui devrait être signé en
septembre prochain la france adopté
l'option zéro
aucun autre essai nucléaire de quelques
niveaux pincio à ces images d'archivés
des premières expérimentations française
américaine ou soviétique seront
rejointes au rayon des antiquités par
celle des essais souterrains dans ce
départ toutefois les américains
souhaitent se réserver la possibilité de
reprendre quelques essais si la
fiabilité de leur arsenal était en jeu
quant à la chine elle est jugée par les
puissances du club comme incontrôlable
cette décision de stopper définitivement
tout essai nucléaire sera bien
évidemment beaucoup commentée en
français à l'étranger nous y reviendrons
longuement demain tout de suite vous
propose d'entendre le commentaire à
chaud d'un représentant de la majorité
du dr gilles de robien
le porte-parole du ps françois hollande
est celui du mouvement antinucléaire
greenpeace
nous sommes satisfaits mais nous avons
des regrets parce que je pense qu'on
pouvait arriver à cette position
beaucoup plus tôt et que et c'est en ce
sens que nous ne sommes pas d'accord
avec le président de la république des
six essais qui ont été engagées elles
n'ont pas amélioré la fiabilité de notre
dissuasion nucléaire et qu on aurait pu
donc sans ses six essais garder la
fiabilité et éviter à l'opinion
internationale de montrer la france tu
dois mais aujourd'hui l'essentiel est
acquis
des essais sont terminés et le traité
sera signé d'une certaine façon c'est un
soulagement parce que les essais
nucléaires ce n'est la tasse de thé de
personnes mais vraiment c'était pour le
président de la république un test de
volonté et de fermeté et le président la
république a montré qu il ne transigeait
pas quand il s'agissait tout simplement
des intérêts fondamentaux de la france
il a pensé aux générations qui viennent
et ses générations le droit à la paix et
ces générations le droit à un pays qui
sera disposé d'une agression éventuelles
je crois qu'aujourd'hui c'est une est
une bataille de 25 ans pour
l'organisation une première partie de la
bataille de 25 ans qui s'achève
je crois qu'aujourd'hui de manière un
petit peu paradoxal greenpeace va se
retrouver sur les mêmes bancs de
négociations que le gouvernement
français pour obtenir cette option zéro
ont traité d'interdiction totale des
essais est ce que nous pouvons espérer
ce soir c'est que la france fasse preuve
d'autant de détermination à parvenir à
cette option zéro qu'elle anime
détermination à continuer ses essais
nucléaires
la semaine dernière en conseil des
ministres le gouvernement a adopté deux
ordonnances sur le rétablissement des
comptes de la sécurité sociale
parmi les dispositions qui vont entrer
en vigueur en février dans quelques
jours une mesure qui a provoqué de vives
réactions de la part des associations
familiales celle qui impose un plafond
de ressources au versement de la paje la
location pour jeunes enfants
précisions avec et remettez et roger
matures ça ne se voit pas encore mais
cécile le noir attend son premier bébé
pour le mois d'août prochain
si elle l'avait conçu huit semaines plus
tôt elle aurait touché à partir de
février comme toutes les mères jusqu'à
présent la location pour jeunes enfants
soit 950 5 francs par mois du quatrième
mois de grossesse jusqu'au troisième
mois de l'enfant désormais cette aide
est soumise à conditions de ressources
avec les 5400 francs nets par mois
qu'elle gagne en tant que comptable et
les 7400 francs de son mari livreurs et
le noir sont au dessus du plafond et ne
toucheront pas la location
on attendait donc de la toucher
effectivement pour pouvoir acheter du
mobilier pour l'enfant au parti
l'armoire le lit la table à langer et
c'est le gros mobilier le landau la
poussette ce qui est nécessaire pour
pour débuter avec un vent fort font peu
dommage quoi parce que c'était une
allocation qui qui donnait je veux dire
un peu d'argent aux jeunes ménages
surtout que c'est toujours dur de
commencer quoiqu'une d'avoir un premier
enfant
c'est pas facile quoi
gouvernement explique-t-il préfère
supprimer l'allocation pour les familles
aisées pour concentrer les aides sur les
familles modestes les associations
familiales répondent que les familles
modestes sont touchés et rappelle que la
consommation est en panne en baisse et
le pouvoir d'achat de beaucoup de
familles alors on voit pas pomarel
pourront acheter plus y compris l'état
pal alger et tout ce qu'il faut pas y
aller une année face le premier ministre
a annoncé pour le mois de mars une
conférence nationale sur la politique de
la famille avec 1,65 enfants par femme
la france connaît aujourd'hui son plus
faible taux de fécondité depuis 1914
face à la montée du chômage et au
ralentissement de la conjoncture paris
et bonn seront annoncées demain
simultanément des mesures de relance de
l'économie
côté allemand ce programme d'urgence
annonce assez musclé avec entre autres
la suppression de subventions et d'
avantages fiscaux en contrepartie d'une
baisse de certains impôts comme celui de
l'impôt de solidarité dont la baisse
pour 97 a été confirmée aujourd'hui par
le gouvernement allemand les
prélèvements obligatoires comme on dit
sont ils actuellement plus important en
allemagne ou en france
reportage avec ce report réponse pardon
avec ce reportage de notre correspondant
permanent jérôme cathala une entreprise
modèle un ouvrier modèle un tableau pas
aussi parfait qu'il en a l'air car
michael pause ims qui n'est pas vraiment
satisfait de son sort
l'argent que je gagne chez bmw ne me
sert qu'à payer le nécessaire alors une
fois par semaine je travaille aussi
comme chauffeur de taxi chauffeur de
taxi un deuxième métier qui permet à
mikel de s'en sortir
ce n'est pas son salaire d'ouvrier
spécialisé chez bmw qu'il remet en cause
mais le niveau jugé exorbitant des
différents prélèvements
démonstration avec sa feuille de paye
michael gagne plus de 4500 marque à peu
près 6000 francs
mais les impôts prélevés à la source et
les fonctions sociales lui retire plus
du quart de son salaire soit 5000 francs
chaque mois et encore et il privilégié
avec ses deux enfants à charge et une
femme au chômage un qu'elle bénéficie du
maximum d'exonération
car loin devant les etats-unis ou la
grande-bretagne et loup
devant la france l'allemagne et
championne des prélèvements fiscaux des
prélèvements qui demain devraient être
revus à la baisse
même s'il ya une baisse des impôts ça ne
changera relève ici les prix augmentent
tellement entre le loyer les transports
ou l'école des enfants tout ce que je
dois financé avec mon salaire est bien
trop important la baisse annoncée des
impôts rêve du salarié français ne
satisfait pas mais qu'elle pose ims qui
sait que ce sont les plus hauts salaires
qui en profiteront lui préférerait que
sa femme retrouvé un emploi c'est bien
d'ailleurs ce que tous les allemands
attendent de leur gouvernement que la
lutte contre le chômage soit demain
vigoureusement relancer et la potion si
possible pas trop amer le plan français
de relance avec notamment des mesures
concernant le logement sera annoncée
demain alain juppé sera à 20 heures
l'invité de la rédaction de france 2
le petit monde du tennis fort troublé
par de sombres affaires de ligne non
point de ligne de fond de court mais
deux lignes de cocaïnes si l'on en croit
en effet l'hebdomadaire britannique news
of the world
mats wilander et karel novacek aurait
fait l'objet d'un contrôle antidopage
positif à la cocaïne lors du dernier
tournoi de roland garros à paris par
jean et orphelins et son père byrne
hogarth et est entré pour toujours dans
la légende de la bande dessinée ce
dessinateur américain l'un des derniers
grands maîtres du 9e art comme l'on dit
est décédé à paris hier soir l'âge de 84
ans byrne regarde revenez du festival
international de la bd d'angoulême où
vous le voyez qui le liraient pourquoi
qu'il honorait de sa présence pour la
première fois et vous voyez l'avait ravi
la vedette à tous les autres
dessinateurs en étant accueillie par une
standing ovation lors de la cérémonie du
palmarès
autre disparition celle du poète russe
naturalisé américain joseph brosky
décédé à new york des suites d'une
attaque cardiaque à l'âge de 55 ans en
87 il avait reçu le prix nobel de
littérature
joseph gross qui vivait aux états unis
depuis 1972 avait été arrêté en urss à
l'âge de 24 ans comme parasite social
il avait été condamné à cinq ans de camp
de travail depuis quelques jours sur nos
grands écrans un film très attachant au
titre assez étrange
visiblement je vous aime ce premier long
métrage de jean michel carré
spécialistes jusqu'à lors de
documentaire a été tourné aux chorales
en camargue un centre d'accueil pour
handicapés mentaux et jeunes délinquants
chacun jouant son propre rôle au milieu
de comédiens professionnels comme denis
lavant reportage caroline morin pascal
pons pour les pensionnaires du choral ce
coin de camargue au milieu des péchés
est un petit paradis
et pourtant ici se côtoient folie et
délinquance comme pour mettre en garde
les visiteurs contre tout jugement
actifs la philosophie de la maison est
affichée sur les murs qui aurait pu dire
qu'un jour ils deviendraient acteurs et
jouerait avec humour leur handicap
de nuit comme un cap et y lit faire le
café le vie mais lui durant huit
semaines handicapés mentaux et comédiens
professionnels ont joué sous la
direction de jean michel carré
c'est l'histoire simple d'un délinquant
récidiviste il viendrait confié coeur
purger sa peine au corral c'est à dire
que tout individu qui soit délinquants
cas social psychotique autistes il a des
capacités à lui et ses capacités la de
créativité en général qui sont
thérapeutiques qui peuvent l'aider à
être un citoyen comme vous et moi
samuel n'avait pas de langage
à bourg et j'aime chaque arrêt lui a
demandé de dire certaines phrases puis
un jour ses sorties il a commencé à
faire des phrases avec sujet vers le
complément naturel
comment on a pu arriver des choses comme
ça qu'on fait dans ma jeunesse à
montreux tétouan chambert il m'a gonflé
et c'est une grippe et silencieuse de
personnes l'écoutent et prend
aujourd'hui la parole dont les salles de
cinéma avec leurs mots il faut tomber
les dernières barrières de
l'incompréhension devant un public
conquis
ils deviennent ambassadeurs de tous les
lieux de vie hors de l'hôpital de guéret
pour la petite histoire grâce à l'argent
du film le choral compte un pensionnaire
de plus sultan le cheval de marinette
son rêve de toujours
vers 23h30 le dernier journal en
compagnie de philippe le fait ici et
nulle part ailleurs je me dois de
souhaiter une bonne fête aux gildas un
bon anniversaire à sacha distel 63 ans
et toutes ses dents et à l'académie
française fondée il y à 3 161 ans demain
dans les 4 vérités gérard leclerc à 7h50
recevra le socialiste henri emmanuelli
dans un instant la météo de nathalie
rihouet avec une amélioration globale du
temps mais toujours on l'a dit de
faibles pluies sur le roussillon à 13h
vous retrouver patrick chesnais j'aurai
le plaisir de retrouver à 20h excellente
soirée merci
je ne